And then this one, I think it's hummus
Oh yeah, it's been way too long since I've had hummus
Hey everyone! It's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com in Bangkok, Thailand
When you're about to take a trip, especially if you're travelling
somewhere that you've never been before
You get this overwhelming feeling of excitement
and that excitement I think it can come from many different things
maybe kind of going into the unknown,
or maybe it's the excitement you get from
wanting to do and see and experience and eat as much as you can when you're there
In a couple of hours from now, actually later tonight
Ying and I are flying from Bangkok to the Kingdom of Jordan
And I think Jordan is maybe as different or opposite as you can get from Thailand,
in terms of climate and culture and food and maybe just about everything
And I am extremely excited to be going to Jordan
It's now 9 PM, we are fully packed and we're gonna go catch a taxi to the airport,
And it's gonna be pretty cold, not too cold in Jordan, but definitely a lot colder than in Bangkok
So we're bringing the jackets and we're all packed up
We're in a taxi on our way to Suvarnabhumi Airport,
which is the main international biggest airport in Bangkok
Traffic was light, but at the airport it's really busy tonight
Suvarnabhumi Airport is just packed all the time,
full of people
It's about 10 PM now and our flight is at 12:30 AM,
we're actually leaving tommorow which makes it a little bit confusing,
so you have to like think the day before, but we're actually leaving tommorow
We made it through customs and immigration and then walked to our gate
Ying and I were invited by the Jordan tourism board to visit Jordan
so we're gonna be going there, we're gonna focus our trip mainly on food,
but at the same time we have a pretty full schedule while we're in Jordan,
we're gonna be travelling around seeing some of the famous sites and attractions,
and eating lots of delicious food, I'm anticipating it already
It's gonna be a 9 hour flight to reach Amman,
I'm getting really really sleepy though, I actually fell asleep right as we took off,
so I'm gonna go eat dinner and then probably sleep for a couple hours,
and I will keep you all updated
Cold breeze just hit me as we exited the plane, it's 5 AM,
we just landed in Amman, I think I slept quite a bit on the plane
YIng welcome to Jordan, welcome to Jordan!
Okay
Oh! I've been feeling that cold there
It was a breeze to get through immigration and customs, and we picked up our bag
The airport was nice and quiet, and there was a representative from visit Jordan the tourism board,
who got our visas for us, we just stepped outside and it is much colder than Bangkok
Hold on! Oh my jacket, it's here I think right?
Oh! There it is
It's about 8 degrees celcius, it's not too cold, but it is cold enough to wear a jacket,
that's for sure!
Oh!
All right!
And we just met up with Fadhi, who is gonna be our guide for the trip,
we're gonna take a car I think to our hotel here in Amman now
-We're looking forward to this trip very much!
-Wonderful!
Okay, is it your first time to this part of the world, Mark?
-I have been to Egypt
-Ah Okay!
-About 4 years ago
-This mosque has one of the biggest of 3 standing domes in the world,
-Wow!
and look at what's on the other side of the road, opposite to the mosque,
is a Catholic Church
-Oh Okay!
-And that's how it is in Jordan,
we're next to each other, across from each other and we live in harmony
-La Locanda
-If you've been to Egypt, locanda means motel
That was about a 30 minute drive, we just arrived to our hotel,
we're gonna be staying at a hotel called La Locanda
And this is a very old area of Amman and Fadhi was explaining to me that
it's coming back though, many people are investing here now,
and it's kind of an art and heritage center of Amman
-Look at the size of that door Ying!
-Haha!
-Okay so the magnet, just put the magnet it goes downwards to the right
-Downwards to the right
-Right in here
-All right, oh yeah
-There was a click
-Good
We are just stepping into our room very nice little place, this is a boutique hotel
and all of the rooms have different names that are all different Arabic artists
-Oh Wow! Nice room!
-Nice
Nice and bright and white
-Is that the bathroom over there?
-Yeah
-I don't know how to use this thing?
-What is what thing?
-This thing
-Oh, that is the bidet
shower over here, have the toilet and the bidet, sink over here
I like the style is very minimal, but everything you need,
but not overly fancy or not overly decorative just really nice and clean
Trying to open this window, is this a window or a door?
And this is our view
Very nice!
Oh that is some really cool fresh air coming from that window
Oh check out that orange tree!
One of the nicknames for Amman is the White City because all of the buildings and
all of the houses are white because of the limestone that is used for the construction
And I've only been in Amman now for 30 minutes,
but I can already see just from looking out our window that
all of the buildings are so white and what I really loved is the contrast between
the white buildings and the really blue sky
I just took a shower, that felt incredible! And I was wondering why I was so hungry,
I'm so hungry right now and then I looked at the time back in Bangkok
it's right at noon and so it's lunch time in Bangkok
The good news is breakfast, we're gonna down to breakfast in about 15 minutes
And the breakfast is buffet style so you just walk through and
get whatever you want, they had a number of different vegetables, raw vegetables
plus some different dips some hummus and some different types of bread
Oh also got some hard baked egg and there is some rice on the bottom
I think so that it doesn't stick, I'm not sure there is some rice on the bottom of the egg in the pan
Let me crack that
I'm gonna chop this in half
and I think it could use a little bit of pepper
Some pepper, all right, all right
and then some like pita bread, I think I'm gonna add some of the egg and maybe
Oh! That just fell out, add the egg to this bread
and then there is this sauce over here which is I think this one is hummus
and then this one it's like a creamy very creamy sauce maybe I don't know
I'll dip it in that and see what it is
It tastes like a sour cream, very very creamy
And then this one I think is hummus
Oh yeah!
It's been way too long since I've had hummus and
that is like it's a little bit sour maybe with lemon juice and then very very smooth and a little bit starchy
That is an extremely like very creamy and very smooth hummus
As I was eating my first plate of breakfast they brought out some ful and
so I had to get another plate of food
I'm just gonna take a bite of these beans
Oh yeah!
That is soft and like refried beans, but with kind of chewy skins to the beans
Oh it's so good! And with olive oil I put a little bit of olive oil over them too,
makes it even better
That was good, I like the mix of vegetables and then I'm glad they brought out some ful at the end
That was really good!
And I just stepped outside, I had no idea, I wasn't expecting it to rain
It's not raining right now, but it just drizzled a little bit
I'm getting really sleepy so I think we're gonna go take a nap in the room for a few hours
Stay tuned lots more videos from Jordan to come
Thank you for watching this video please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
And I will see you tomorrow for our first full day in Amman